aha I thought my jokes were bad
everybody is Charlie we got our first
preview for Todd Phillips Joker movie
Joaquin Phoenix as this character Arthur
so when I first saw this I was like
what's going on so I'll explain the new
origin story that they're doing for this
character how this fits into the grander
DC Universe continuity in how they're
treating sort of their spin-off DC Black
Label which is a brand new thing with in
the film universe I'm still doing that
DC streaming service giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so first things first if you have
no idea what's going on
Joaquin Phoenix is playing Joker during
the Joker spin-off film they're doing an
origin story for him whether or not you
feel like the Joker deserves a
definitive origin story because there's
at least eight different versions that
we've seen between the movies the TV
shows in the comic books what they're
doing with this version is that they're
calling him Arthur Fleck and if you've
heard about the martin scorsese joker
project this film is actually inspired
by the king of comedy so I'll do a quick
explainer for the plot of that movie
because as you can see the scene that
they're filming right here is around
this haha' comedy club and most of you
know that Robert De Niro is a character
in the film he's the owner of the comedy
club where Joker goes this haha' Club so
king of comedy inspired you have the
king of comedy himself in the movie so
we'll see how many Easter eggs they put
in in and around what looks like a
suicide slum type of area so I don't
know how the matically closed they'll be
- the king of comedy they haven't said
exactly what year it is during the
course of this movie but I think because
the Joker is several years older than
Batman you can assume that this might be
somewhere 80's 90's and the Batman is
like a really young kid because they
talked about Thomas Wayne being a really
big character during the film the thing
about that is that alec baldwin was
actually named as thomas wayne and
people were like oh wow
he was actually supposed to be batman
during Tim Burton's Batman so this is
bringing it around full circle I mean
obviously he went with Michael Keaton
and that was fantastic he was a great
version of Batman but you do kind of
wonder what the Alec Baldwin version of
Batman was going to be so what happened
is is there was a report that the
version of Thomas Wayne that we were
gonna see during this
would be inspired by Trump which made a
bunch of people me included freak out
just a little bit like wait a minute I
don't want that kind of a Thomas Wayne
because Thomas Wayne is actually
supposed to be a really gentle person in
Batman's history like you look at the
Christopher Nolan version of Thomas
Wayne that's typically what you think of
when you think of that character did you
build the string Gotham's being done to
our family but the city's been suffering
people less fortunate to master leaving
during very hard times so important no
public transportation says so hearing
that they might be getting all political
with that character just sounded way too
on-the-nose so after that people were
freaking out to Alec Baldwin's Twitter
handle because he is active on Twitter
and he responded by saying this is
ridiculous I am totally not doing this
they don't need me to play that
character they can get anybody to do
that so he quit the part within like a
day or so of the studio announcing him
as that character which is kind of
unfortunate but I think it's important
to say that they're not turning the
Joker into a hero even though this is
his own movie like I don't think they're
meaning to turn him into an antihero the
way that the Suicide Squad is supposed
to feel like a bunch of anti heroes but
again it helps if you understand the
plot in the themes of the King of Comedy
movie because that's meant to be a
really dark comedy all about the bad
aspects of celebrity worship in American
media culture during that movie Robert
De Niro's character is an aspiring
comedian but he's mentally deranged he
worships Jerry Lewis's character who's
sort of this really successful comedian
within the context of the film so he
wants to do everything he can to become
famous like him but at every turn Jerry
Lewis's character rebuffs him so when
Robert De Niro's character fails trying
the legit way to become famous and
closer to Jerry Lewis's character so
that pushes Robert DeNiro who's already
a mentally deranged character off the
deep end so he decides the only way to
become famous is to kidnap Jerry Lewis
with another compos who's also obsessed
with him and wants to go on this crazy
dream date with him think you know think
about Joker Harley Quinn pairing so he
tells the producers of Jerry Lewis's TV
show you have to let me go on and do my
comedy set so that I can be famous then
I'll release him so the producers agree
to his demands he
goes on live television doing his comedy
bit telling a story there's really sad
story about his upbringing how he was
abused in the audience starts eating it
up at the end of the set he confesses to
kidnapping Jerry Lewis and says that
he's going to set him free but it was
better to be king for a night than a
schmuck for a lifetime so they arrest
him Jerry Lewis eventually gets away in
Wally's in prison he starts pinning an
autobiography meaning that he'll
continue to be famous so is this really
twist to take on celebrity worship and
how people do really underhanded things
to become famous it's really really dark
comedy so imagine the origin of the
Joker flows a lot from that type of
energy where he's trying to become a
comedian and it takes this really dark
twisted turn what we don't know though
is what is sets him off what are the
triggers because during the dark night
films The Joker feels like he wants to
expose the truth of all these people
that Batman's trying to protect these
good people when the chips are down
they'll eat each other so he feels like
that's a fundamental truth that he's
trying to get everyone to realize
primarily Batman though so it sounds
like his arc during this movie is gonna
be coming to that realization slowly
like he slowly tries to become a
comedian then comes to realize this
grand truth about everything and tries
to get everyone else to realize it too I
wouldn't be surprised though if he
spends the first act of the film looking
like this
the way they're explaining how this film
fits into the continuity is is that it's
the beginning of DC black label films
which is sort of like a spin-off
Elseworlds universe of stories where
they can do whatever they want
one-off films that don't have to tie to
Justice League in what's going on with
the other big DC films so think of it as
say like watching the flash movie and
watching the flash TV show but they're
both two different characters neither
one has anything to do with the other
one is just one group of people's take
on the character the other is a
completely different take so like I said
though there have been at least eight
different versions of the Joker's origin
story across all the movies the comics
in the different TV shows I think one of
the most important things that this
movie needs to do is just let everybody
know that there is no official
definitive origin story for the Joker
you can tell as many as you want and I
think people will be on board for that
as long as they don't try to lock this
in as the official Canon like this is
the only way this is the
true story of the Joker everybody else
has been just doing their own spin on it
thankfully so far that's kind of how
they've been selling the film at least
people like Geoff Johns like the other
big comic book people that have been
associated with DC and DC movies like
they're just like this is gonna be its
own thing we're gonna continue to do
this with other projects as they come up
but the whole reason for this DC black
label of films to exist this Elseworlds
universe is is because what happens is
is bigger actors like Joaquin Phoenix
Todd Phillips even Martin Scorsese
is is they don't want to sign on for
like six or seven films which is a
pretty standard comic book film deal
like I think Ben Affleck had five movies
on his Batman contract and typically the
better bigger more powerful filmmakers
they might be a big comic book fans they
might have a really interesting idea for
a DC film but they don't want to tell 5
DC stories they just want to do a
one-and-done thing so that's what this
Elseworlds DC black label Universal
films are supposed to be and even within
that self-contained universe I don't
think that those films or any other
future films that they might make that
would be Elseworlds are supposed to be
connected but I think as we get more
information and they'll start explaining
more about that kind of stuff they have
a fantastic cast I think it'd just be
interesting to see what this is actually
gonna look like when they start dropping
footage right now it's scheduled for
release the first week in October next
year so like we're getting ready to go
see venom the first week in October in a
couple weeks next year around this time
we'll be watching that Joker movie we
might not get an official teaser till
early next year I think Aquaman in
December is a little too soon but just
let me know what you think of the look
of this so far I know it's kind of weird
like we're all still trying to get used
to the idea of two different jokers
existing congratulations Amadeus Jones
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that
Titans Batman trailer and click here for
that last big flash trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]